How is a biofeedback protocol different or the same as a rife machine?
What I've researched is this. Biofeedback teaches you how to regulate your own systems,
your conscious awareness and practice. It's participatory and retrains your body of mind.
Rife delivers external frequencies to shift or disrupt patterns in the body. It's more of
a treatment you received rather than a skill you learned. So would do it both be beneficial or over
the top with what I might need. So biofeedback is kind of a bioinform of neural feedback.
So neural feedback was developed decades ago. That involves putting actually a little electrodes
on your head at different points on your skull and you basically retraining your brain
to get to different waves. So you have different brain waves. Beta wave is your
wave that you're very intent and you're concentrating and hopefully you're functioning at beta wave
listening to me right now and you're in a learning mode. And then you have alpha waves,
theta waves. And so you have these waves that you have to get down to, I've said,
I think last call, you have to get down to like a theta in order to help you get to sleep.
Many times people have emotional issues, partly because their brain can be stuck at a
high wave or a low wave. And you can use neural feedback, aka biofeedback, to help you
kind of cognitively control your thought processes and emotions. It is very
scientific. It's been proven over and over again. And it's a great therapy. So is it different
than rife? It's 100% different than rife. Rife you're using, so for instance, when you're talking
about the frequencies of when we're talking about neural feedback, you're talking about frequencies
about 7 to 30. 30 is your high beta wave. This is what I've said over and over again about
when a person can't fall asleep, you've got to stop watching screens. You've got to stop your
screen time meeting. Stop looking at your phones, stop looking at the TV, stop looking at your iPad
like an hour before bed because the screens are vibrated at 60 hertz. So you're basically in what's
called doing brain and treatment. That's what biofeedback does. That's what neurofeedback does.
It's what's called brain and treatment. You're trading your brain at a theta wave or an alpha wave
or a beta wave. Well, when you're when you're looking at a screen, you're basically
trading your brain at 60 hertz, which is an ultra high beta wave. That's not good. When you're
looking at that screen, it's your your brain is firing at a very high waveform and then you have to
get down to a theta wave to get to sleep. Some people can drop their brain down to a theta wave and
think happy thoughts and relax and fall asleep in 10 minutes after they after they pull the covers up.
Some people they lay there for an hour because their brain is still really that they're trying to
get it down to 45 down to 40 down to 30 down to 25 and it takes a long time because their mind is
just rolling. Everybody's experienced that, you know, you're under a lot of stress. You're thinking
about, you know, your your new office move that you got coming up and you're you're thinking about
a million things you have to do. You're planning your wedding, your daughter's wedding or something.
You're thinking of a million things to do. In order for you to think and plan, you're at a beta
state and you can't figure out why you can't go to sleep and your brain is just rolling your thinking
of a zillion things to do. Well, you can do biofeedback or neurofeedback to call your brain down. There's
a number of different devices that can be really good to help call a brain down to get to the state
to help fall asleep. So I'm using sleep as an example, but you could use neurofeedback slash biofeedback
for a lot of different things, but the number one use of it is in trying to get trying to call
an overactive brain. Not just for sleep, but for like OCD issues and anxiety issues and things
like that, ADD, ADHD type additions. I personally used to use I personally old neurofeedback clinic
about what was it 15 years ago. Well, that's what I had another doctor working for me that kind of
headed up that clinic. We were both certified in neurofeedback and it was wonderful. It was just too much
of a play. So I basically just we got on with it. But it was it could be a wonderful tool. So
long answer to yes, they're both beneficial, totally different. But I would absolutely if you're
doing something like that or you consider doing something like that, it could be extremely helpful.